this was crazy it really hurts Kiki
Palmer gets real about breastfeeding
come on let's talk about it as her
boyfriend Darius Jackson compares her to
during an Instagram live the actress is
in full mambos pumping milk for her baby
boy leotis I had to pump it out
this is crazy it really hurts my nipples
are like this is what I've been looking
at half the time seriously half the day
she just be you know
trying to get this
Furious gets a little nostalgic looking
at Kiki can you remind me of you remind
me of um not the last Batman but the one
the um the one with George Clooney
Batman arrival
I freeze I'm Batman
or Arnold Schwarzenegger when he came
making all those puns it's time for
freeze and then he kept freezing the
damn City tonight
[Music]
but they had Bane in there Bane had all
these damn cords connected to him behold
machine I call this little number
Bane
with my pump you know we're gonna just
shock you with my pump you already know
since giving birth to little Leo in
February Kiki's kept it candid when it
comes to sharing her life as a new mom
your girl is ready for the park from all
the highs
to the lows I just came over here to say
if you are a single parent
pull out your cape when it comes to
raising a kid I've already learned in
these short few days that
it takes a village
um and sometimes that's a privilege and
I just want anybody out there that is a
single parent that's been doing this
um friends of mine people that I don't
know family members of mine
I'm really in my in my heart
bring tears to my eyes I am just truly
profoundly impressed despite the
struggles Kiki seems to be enjoying the
mom life
[Music]
goodbye